This is really cool.
When I wrote it in Ushimaki, I surrounded people who didn't seem like it.
I'm not thinking about whether or not I can drink it, but if it can be used for work, it should have an
arm or a winch.
When
I was a kid, I didn't draw blueprints for secret bases. It was
really fun, wasn't it?
That's why I'm thinking about the world of today,
so I'm buying money to write it.
I want a gimmick that has more character and moves flashy
.
I changed the flight to a contra-rotating propeller,
and attached a book, but I haven't reached
[Music]
By the way, the surface of the wings is a solar panel.
Hi-chan, I have no choice but to feed my brother
Thank you so much Jazz
[music]
7 ona